today's questions from Peter I in Texas
I'm a single 25 year old and baby step 2
a couple of good friends getting married
this year they're planning a destination
wedding how do I budget in the cost of
not only a gift but the flights hotel
rooms the extra cocktail parties and
outings that go along with a destination
wedding I don't want to miss out on the
experience because these are good
friends but they are going to be
expensive
well you're not alike my answer
broke people should not go to
destination weddings that's my answer
destination wedding is an excuse for a
vacation it's a wonderful thing for
people that have money but when broke
people go to a destination wedding you
know what you call that more debt
because even if you budgeted the money
out of your income and used it it's
money you would have been paying down on
your debt so effectively you borrowed
the money to go to a destination wedding
and I got to tell you I think it's a bad
idea
see I just here's the funny thing I was
in
when share and I got married you know
you go through that phase everybody
knows getting married so you're in all
the weddings and then everybody knows
having babies and so everybody has baby
shower and then everybody you know is
doing this and everybody knows doing
that and everybody you go through this
phase of life with your friends you know
the number of people that I was in their
wedding that I still see 25 years later
hey one maybe I'm not mad at him I
didn't get mad at him it wasn't I was a
jerk or they were a jerk they just moved
away and doctor and dr. Malone it's okay
it's just kind of life but so probably
whether I bought them a baby shower gift
or not it's probably going to be okay
one way or the other
and you sure as a flip can afford to fly
to Mexico and go to somebody's wedding
when you're broke so see that's just
that sounds like I'm a no fun guy I'm
not a no fun guy I believe in living
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else as a matter of fact a
friend of ours is getting married his
kid is getting married in a destination
wedding and I think we're going to go
and I we like to kid and we certainly
love our friend and that would be but
you know what we're going because it
kind of sounds like fun
because we've lived like no one else and
now we're not broken we can do that but
my 25 year old son might not be able to
afford to do that he maybe can but a lot
of people can't at 25 years old and he's
been in good gosh he's in a wedding
every weekend
what is wrong with you people is the
average wedding party now 15 people or
something I mean it was just we used to
go see the preacher and he went yeah
done and you were gone I mean it was
like wow this is a dadgum Hollywood
production every one of these things now
my kids - do I make my daughters had big
weddings we're not mad about this it's
just an interesting shift in the culture
a lot of things have shifted since I was
since I had hair but um yeah so anyway
no no I can't you know you asked me so
you get
my answer I'm sorry it goes with the
territory I would have to say if I were
in your shoes and I were twenty three or
twenty six and I had no money I could
not go on a destination wedding and
you'll live through it and they'll live
through it
basically what are you missing a
vacation and you're broke broke people
don't need to be going on vacation broke
people need to be working and not being
broke people anymore to live like no one
else so later you can live like no one
else and just I you do whatever you want
I got a feeling I'm not talking you out
of this is what I'm yakking about it and
some of you people are rolling your eyes
go a can't believe you telling nothing
on that wedding but I mean really
seriously I can promise you twenty five
years from now there's about a 90%
probability of zero relationship with
these people that you're about to go in
debt to go their wedding that's the
truth and that might be if it's your
sister even it could be I know I don't
know about your family but for sure
friends I mean I can and again I haven't
had a falling out with a bunch of my
friends it wasn't anything like that
and a bunch of them you know it's like
how many people do you still talk to
from high school thirty five years after
you graduate from high school one
there's four hundred or something in our
graduating class again I'm not mad at I
think I'm staying touch with four or
five of them as long it's and you know
once a year on that basis so I'm not
going to suggest you reform your life on
something that might not be as permanent
a relationship as you feel like it is
right now hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]